box to find and view recent and featured
programs
october 16th marked the 150th
anniversary of abolitionist john brown's
attack on the u.s armory and arsenal in
harpers ferry west virginia
brown went to trial following his
capture and was hanged in charlestown
west virginia on december 2nd 1859.
author brian mcginty discusses the john
brown trial from the courthouse where it
took place in charlestown west virginia
good evening everyone and welcome to the
courthouse in jefferson county the
circuit court of jefferson county before
i begin any remarks i'd like to
notice that
the courthouse has just now reached
the final stage of what has been six
months of renovations
kirk davis who is with the county here
capital improvement for jefferson county
has been shepherding this project along
and this is the first meeting of any
nature that we've had here in the newly
refurbished
courtroom so
we're very proud of it and of all the
work that kirk there kirk is standing
there kirk wants you to raise your hand
there's kirk
before i introduce tonight's speaker
i've been asked to give some background
about the courthouse itself
in 1803 two years after jefferson county
was created the first courthouse was
built on this spot on land donated by
george washington's younger brother
charles it was a modest structure and it
housed the county court which was
equivalent to a county commission in a
magistrate court
in 1812 a superior court was created in
virginia and it was for this district it
was housed in winchester
and it wasn't until 1831 oh by the way i
remind myself please turn off your cell
phones in any device any electrical
devices please go ahead and turn them
off if you would please
it was 1812 when superior court was set
up in winchester and it would be 1831
before a moveable or a circuit superior
court was created in the commonwealth of
virginia for this district and its first
session was in may of 1831 presided over
by judge richard parker of winchester
who was the father and namesake of the
judge who would try john brown
in 1836 the first courthouse was pulled
down and a larger one was constructed in
the greek revival style that had been
popularized by thomas jefferson and
which characterizes virginia courthouses
from this period the new courthouse had
a portico topped by a bell tower
pot-bellied stoves heated the building
which had an assembly hall on its second
floor and a stable in the rear
the ground floor was taken up by a huge
courtroom and it was this ground floor
courtroom in which john brown was tried
in october of
1859 now during the civil war
particularly in 1863 the courthouse was
heavily damaged by shelling
and luckily the court records had been
taken
by wagon to lexington for safe keeping
and thus survived the war but by the
wars in the courthouse was a sad empty
and ruthless ruin
a photograph from that time shows that
there were tombstones that were being
sold in the courthouse yard in front and
you can see the rafters the bear rafters
above
in 1866 a new courthouse was built in
shepherdstown which had been made the
county seat
by the federal troops occupying the
county in 1869 county officials tried to
sell the brick and timbers of the old
courthouse in the jail for scrap
but charlestown residents argued that
the building was theirs and not the
counties to sell
the bitter struggle as to which town
would be the county seat was decided by
the west virginia supreme court in july
of 1871 and a disappointed shepherdstown
almost seceded from the county
the ruined courthouse would now be
reconstructed it would be bigger
stronger taller the bell tower was
increased fantastically in size and a
clock was added weight-bearing walls
partitioned the ground floors into
offices the exterior walls windows and
columns were raised higher and to create
a space for a grand new courthouse
courtroom upstairs
the basic layout of the courtroom the
position of the judge the jury box the
well of the
accord enclosed with railing is similar
to that of the john brown courtroom in
which john brown was tried a gigantic
gas chandelier was put in for evening
sessions a balcony was added which was
referred to as the ladies listening
gallery but seems an awful lot like a
jim crow balcony of that same period
they had a different way of explaining
it at that time however
for 40 years from 1873
until 1912 this courtroom would be the
home of the west one of the homes of the
west virginia supreme court of appeals
in its early days our supreme court was
a circuit riding court and during its
three terms each year it set one term in
wheeling which had been the original
state capital one in charleston and one
here in charlestown
in 1922 the s this upstairs courtroom
would see its own treason trials the
mine wars were raging in southwestern
west virginia and union organizer bill
blizzard and over 700 coal miners have
been charged with murder and treason
following their armed attempt to
unionize logan county in what had become
known as the battle of blair mountain
those cases were transferred to
jefferson county and all the trials that
were had including the trial which
acquitted bill blizzard were held in
this very courtroom
unlike some venerated buildings rich in
symbolism and history the jefferson
county courthouse is not a museum but
remains a working courthouse it still
houses the circuit court and many
offices of county government
births deaths taxes land transactions
are all recorded here people are married
and divorced here
pettit juries grand jury still sit in
regular session petty jury still resolve
controversies civil and criminal
affecting a growing population elections
are held in the results tabulated and
announced here this famous building is
at the very heart of our civic life
a lot has happened here and is still
happening here however the lynchpin
story in the entire history of this old
building this old courthouse is the
trial of john brown
here to tell us that story tonight is a
man steeped in the details and
significance of that famous trial
about a year ago i was giving a
courthouse tour when two men asked to
tag along and when i got to the subject
of john brown it became apparent that
one of the tourists knew a great deal
more than the tour guide our small group
delighted in the added depth the tour
suddenly took on this was my first
encounter with brian mcginty
he introduced himself as a retired
lawyer and a historian
he told us of his intention to write the
very book that he is here to speak of
tonight
needless to say i was excited and i am
greatly pleased and honored that he
graciously agreed to come here tonight
on the official date of the book's
release
on this eve of the sesquicentennial of
john brown's raid on harpers ferry
an accomplished writer mr mcginty has
authored seven books of which john
brown's trial is only his most recent
published by harvard university press
in february of 2008 harvard press
published mr mcginty's lincoln and the
court which dealt with lincoln's
suspension of habeas corpus his struggle
with chief justice roger taney and the
supreme court's decisions during the
civil war
in his book the oatman massacre
published by oklahoma university press
in 2006 mr mcginty explored a famous
southwestern indian massacre of a mormon
family and the cat and which took two of
the children captive
among earlier books by mr mcginty are
patareski at paso robles about the great
polish pianist and his love for a small
california town mr mcginty is an amateur
pianist and strong wine the life and
legend of arguston
uh heresty the definitive biography of
the colorful father of california venti
culture published by stanford university
press in 1998. obviously mr mcginty
writes about his own interests passion
and passions among them law history
music and wine having spent a career
practicing law in california mr mcginty
has now retired to scottsdale arizona
where he continues to write on history
and the law while pursuing many other
interests ladies and gentlemen it is now
my great pleasure to introduce and would
you please make a warm welcome for mr
brian mcginty
[Applause]
thank you ken sullivan thank you
judge sanders a wonderful introduction
judge sanders felt that i added some
depth to the tour of the courthouse that
he conducted just about one year ago
i think that he added a great deal of
depth to my understanding of the trial
of john brown and i considered a
fortunate day when i met judge sanders
here and he asked me if i would be
interested in coming back
a year hence
when the sesquicentennial commemoration
of john brown's activities in jefferson
county would take place
after arrangements very kindly
facilitated by
ken sullivan and the west virginia
humanities council i agreed to do so and
looking out
across this historic courtroom tonight
i'm very happy that i accepted that
invitation
i had been prepared to make a few
observations about this courthouse and
this courtroom
which are really really very historic
both
because of john brown's uh trial that
took place here but for other reasons as
well
judge sanders has covered that very well
i'm going to get right to the story of
the trial
and at the outset i want to tell you
the thesis that i'm going to
express tonight which is the thesis of
my book
titled john brown's trial it is that
john brown's trial
was the most important trial
in the history of the united states
that's my conclusion after studying it
as closely as i could and that's the uh
purport of my book i've tried to explain
in my book why i believe that to be true
and i'll try to give you a suggestion of
why i believe that to be true in my
remarks here tonight
john brown's trial was the first hist
trial in the history of the united
states to receive massive attention from
national media
it was the first trial in which a
defendant was executed for treason
against a state
as opposed to treason against the united
states
it was the first trial in which an
accused defendant appealed to a
higher law
to justify violent crimes
it was a trial that involved more
than just a determination of an
individual's guilt or innocence
according to
laws laid down in statute books and in
case reports
it was a trial that pitted two starkly
different moral visions against each
other
one of these
uh visions
defended
the institution of chattel slavery
as traditional
necessary
just and worthy of protection from
outside interference particularly from
the outside interference of northern
abolitionists
like john brown the other con condemned
slavery
as an affront to human rights
a violation of god's law
and an embarrassment to a nation that
claimed to be founded
on the self-evident truth
that all men are created equal
in the course of the trial brown did not
argue that he was
innocent of violating the laws of
virginia
laws that prohibited murder
and inciting slaves to rebellion
and committing treason against the
commonwealth of virginia instead he
argued that the laws of virginia that
supported
and protected slavery laws that
condemned hundreds of thousands of men
women and children
to lives of perpetual
oppression and degradation solely
because of their racial backgrounds
were unjust
the trial gave brown a unique
opportunity to express his views on the
subject and he did so in a manner that
inspired americans all over the country
many even in virginia
with the realization that he was a man
of courage
principle
conviction and humanitarian impulses
however much they disagreed with him
however deeply
they condemned his resort to violence in
harpers ferry his trial revealed that he
was not
a mere
thug or cutthroat as many both north and
south had at first believed him
brown's raid on harpers ferry shocked
the nation
it outraged virginians inspiring them
with
revulsion and fear
it aroused in slaveholders throughout
the south a contempt
for northern abolitionists
at the same time it convinced
southerners that northern attacks on
slavery were deeply grounded they would
not soon go away
the south had to defend itself
against the views represented by brown
and many southerners concluded that the
only way to do that
was to cut the ties that bound
the north and the south
this conclusion did not arise from the
raid on harpers ferry but from the trial
that was conducted here in
the jefferson county courthouse 150
years ago
to understand brown's trial it will be
helpful at the outset to
explain a few of the key facts about it
first it was a short
trial
it began in the circuit court of
jefferson county
in the middle of the day on wednesday
october 26
1859 just 10 days after brown launched
his raid in harpers ferry
eight days after he was captured and a
week to the day after he was transferred
from harpers ferry
to charlestown
it continued on thursday the 27th
of october friday the 28th
saturday the 29th
and following a break for sunday
for half a day on monday the 31st of
october at which time
the jury returned its verdict
during most of the trial
brown was suffering from painful
saber wounds
suffering dur suffered during his
capture in harpers ferry and he was
unable to stand or sit
instead he was forced to attend the
trial lying on a cot
covered by a blanket
and at least once he had to be carried
across the street from the jail to the
courtroom now if you want to know what
this trial looked like imagine a man
lying on a cot in the well of this
courtroom
unable to sit or to stand
and compelled to listen
to a trial going on around him that
would result in his hanging that's what
john brown's trial meant to john brown
himself
in all four days of court time were
devoted to the trial
two days after the verdict was announced
brown was brought back into court and
asked if he had anything to say
before a sentence was passed on him he
then delivered his famous
last statement
and the judge sentenced him to death by
hanging
the sentence was carried out on december
2nd
1859 in a field just five blocks from
this courthouse
it was 30 days after the trial was
concluded and just short of five weeks
after it began
this all happened in a remarkably short
time given the circumstances of the case
the indictment presented complicated
issues it took 20 minutes alone
for the court clerk to read the
indictment in open court
difficulty issues were raised by the
trial some not previously dealt with in
any american court
such as for example whether treason
could be committed against a state
whether a person who was not a resident
of a state
and thus owed no allegiance to the state
could be tried for treason against that
state
whether crimes committed in the federal
enclave
such as the u.s army and arsenal and
harpers ferry were properly triable in
federal court
or in state court whether it is proper
to try a defendant who is suffering from
painful wounds and unable to stand or
sit while he's lying on a cot covered by
blankets
the evidence was voluminous
both in terms of oral testimony and
documentary evidence
during the four days of brown's trial
nine attorneys were heard from and
approximately 19 witnesses were examined
it's difficult to determine the exact
number of witnesses because there was no
official transcript of the testimony
the witnesses testimony was recorded by
newspaper reporters and sometimes those
reports were very accurate sometimes
they were rather hazy
there were two prosecuting attorneys
and seven defense attorneys plus at
least a half dozen other lawyers who
were peripherally involved in the
defense either helping to procure
lawyers for brown's defense or
offering advice from the sidelines or
representing some of the other men who
were
captured with john brown in harper's
ferry and brought here for trial
charles harding was the commonwealth
attorney for jefferson county in 1859
and as such authorized by law to
prosecute brown's case
but he was a heavy drinker
and had a volatile sometimes explosive
temperament
he was capable of making some effective
courtroom arguments but not on a
sustained basis
as one of the deputy clerks in
charlestown later remarked when harding
began to speak
if you shut your eyes and listen for the
first few minutes
you would think patrick henry had
returned to earth
after that he dwindled away into
ineptitudes
virginia's governor henry alexander wise
did not cover consider harding competent
to conduct so important to trial and he
called on andrew hunter
one of the most respected attorneys in
charlestown to take overall control of
the proceedings
andrew hunter's portrait is hanging on
the wall behind me
hunter did not like harding in a letter
to the governor he described him as a
quote
prosecutor
i found that letter in the state library
in richmond and he willingly accepted
the governor's call to take charge of
the case
while both hunter and harding appeared
throughout the trial all of the
important trial decisions were made by
hunter
and he shouldered most of the work
hunter was a native of berkeley county
and related by blood or marriage to many
of the aristocratic families of northern
virginia
he was a graduate of washington academy
later washington and lee university and
hampton sydney college and he had for
several years represented the
baltimore and ohio railroad in
virginia the railroad ran straight
through harpers ferry on its way from
baltimore to wheeling
and was one of the most influential
corporations in the country
in the course of his work for the b o
hunter made contact with important men
in maryland and in virginia and amassed
a considerable personal fortune
he lived in a house called hunter hill
on the eastern edge of charlestown
despite his obvious ability however
hunter was
a rather odd choice for the prosecuting
attorney
for he was heavily burdened with what
with what we would today call
conflicts of interest
first he was personally related to one
of the principal victims of brown's
violence in harpers ferry
a man named fontaine beckham
beckham was the mayor of harvard harpers
ferry and in charge of the local
business of the b o railroad
during brown's raid he was peering
around a water tower at the edge of the
arsenal grounds
when a shot from the engine house in
which brown and his men had taken refuge
toward the end of their raid
uh
hit him and he was killed by that shot
hunter's wife elizabeth was beckham's
niece
and the hunter and beckham families were
close
even more striking however andrew
hunter's son
a young attorney named henry hunter who
went to harpers ferry as a militiaman
from charlestown after news of the
brown raid reached
charlestown
he was a militiaman who arrived in the
town and was sitting in a bar of the
wager house which was then the principal
hotel in harpers ferry when he heard the
news that fontaine beckham his great
uncle had been shot
in a rage
triggered by the news and by his own
drinking henry hunter immediately went
into one of the upper rooms of the wager
house
where two of brown's men were being held
captive
to shoot them
but the sister of the hotel proprietor
stood in his way insisting there would
be no shooting in the wager house
so henry hunter then dragged one of
brown's men out of the hotel
where surrounded by a crowd of
townspeople
he shot him to death
it was in effect a murder of a helpless
man committed in broad daylight and
before many witnesses
yet henry hunter was never charged with
this killing
he was never tried
in our time a man like andrew hunter
would be barred from prosecuting brown's
case because of his personal involvement
with the facts of the case
in 1859 he was not barred
and he prosecuted the case to a
courtroom victory
and when brown was hauled out of the
courthouse to the execution grounds
south of town henry hunter
was given a responsible position
among the militiamen who guarded the
site
while brown was hanged
during the civil war the territory
connecting washington dc
with the upper shenandoah valley the
territory that we're now standing on
became a one of the major fields of
battle in the civil war
harpers ferry in charlestown changed
hands
frequently with confederates in charge
one day and union army troops the next
in 1864
union general
david hunter came through charlestown
with his army
it happened that andrew hunter
was david hunter's first cousin but they
supported different sides of the
conflict
general hunter was an abolitionist
and andrew hunter was the defendant of
slavery and a legal adviser to robert e
lee
when general hunter arrived in
charlestown he ordered his men to burn
andrew hunter's house
to the ground
they did so on july 17 1864
ignoring the protest of andrew hunter's
wife and the other family members who
occupied it
the civil war has often been described
as a war of brothers against brothers
in charlestown at least it was also a
war of
first cousins against first cousins
three of the attorneys who helped brown
in charlestown were court-appointed
attorneys three others were attorneys of
brown's own choosing
all of the attorneys worked under
significant handicaps however because
some of because they didn't sympathize
with brown others because of the very
severe time constraints imposed on them
by the court at the outset
the presiding magistrate of the
examining court appointed lawson bots
and charles faulkner to represent brown
both of these men were well-connected
lawyers who held respected positions in
the aristocracy of northern virginia but
they had been personally present in
harpers ferry during the fighting there
and they had actually fought against
brown
bots had participated in the
negotiations for a truce that would have
permitted brown
to
withdraw from harpers ferry across the
potomac into maryland
and
faulkner had openly expressed his
opinion not only that brown was guilty
but that he deserved just punishment for
his crimes
to his credit faulkner tried to decline
his appointment arguing that he was
disqualified because of his personal
involvement in the raid
and the opinions he had expressed but
the magistrates court insisted that he
represent brown later when the case
reached the circuit court faulkner was
replaced by the mayor of charlestown
thomas claiborne greene
greene too was a well-connected lawyer
the mayor of charlestown
the son of a justice of the virginia
supreme court of appeals
a cousin of virginia's u.s senator james
m mason
and a great grandson of george mason of
gunston hall
the venerated
author of the virginia declaration of
rights
green was an attorney of obvious ability
who in later years became a justice of
the west virginia supreme court of
appeals and i think as such presided in
this courtroom when the
west virginia supreme court of appeals
held its sessions here
the overriding problem with the court
appointed attorneys
was simply that brown did not
choose them to represent him and he had
no confidence in them
shortly after he was captured brown
wrote letters to ohio and massachusetts
in both of which states he had formerly
lived
asking attorneys there to come to
charlestown to represent him in his
co-defendants but by the time the
attorneys were able to respond to
brown's letters
the trial had already begun in
charlestown
without them
the three attorneys who came to
charlestown in response to brown's
letters were hiram griswald from ohio
samuel chilton from washington d.c and
george hoyt from massachusetts
chilton and griswold were
mature attorneys of experience and
special ability but hoyt was only 21
years old and it only recently passed
the massachusetts bar
he was so slight and boyish in his
appearance and when he first arrived in
charlestown
uh people here thought he must be two
years younger and they frankly doubted
that he was really an attorney
hoyt's initial purpose in coming to
charlestown was to reconnoiter the town
the courthouse the jail and advised
brown's supporters back in boston if
there was any way they might help him
escape
but when hoyt met brown in the jail
brown made it clear
that he did not want to escape
he had decided to stay where he was and
face the music
later brown said that he would not walk
out of the jail
even if its doors were thrown open for
him
he knew that there would be gunfire if
he tried to escape the sheriff the
jailer and others might be killed or
injured he had developed special reflect
respect and affection for these men the
sheriff and the jailer particularly and
he did not want to subject them to
danger he would stay in jail
to the bitter end
in the course of my research for the
book i
checked the u.s census records for
northern virginia
to determine whether the men who had
charge of
brown's trial were slave holders
and if so how many slaves they held
the most illuminating records were those
that i found for the census of 1860
which was taken only about six months
after brown's trial came to an end
the records
were to say the least interesting
i found when the 1860 census was taken
the chief prosecutor andrew hunter
owned four slaves
judge richard parker jr
the winchester-based jurist who presided
over the trial
owned ten slaves
brown's court-appointed attorneys were
themselves
slave holders charles faulkner owned 13
lawson bots another of his court
appointed attorneys owned four and
thomas claiborne green the mayor of
charlestown owned another four
i couldn't find all 12 of the jurors in
brown's case in the slaveholders
schedules but those i did find owned
among them
54 slaves
the eight magistrates who formed brown's
examining court owned among them
a total of 105
slaves
altogether these men
owned 194 slaves
the question has often been asked
whether brown's trial was fair
it's a legitimate question it's not an
easy question to answer however
certainly the fact that brown was
surrounded on all sides by slaveholders
militated against the fairness of the
trial
after all he had come into virginia as
he said to free the slaves in effect to
take away the property of the men who
now had his fate in their hands
the prosecutors the judge the jurors
even the attorneys
appointed to represent him it shouldn't
be a surprise that they didn't
sympathize with him
for their own pecuniary interests were
obviously imperiled by his
self-professed
goals another factor that militated
against fairness was the shortness of
the trial and the repeated requests for
modest delays that were denied by judge
parker
there's no question that parker
conducted the trial with haste
but he really had to
for virginia statutes at the time
provided that a person indicted for a
felony had to be indicted
and uh tried
at the same term of the court in which
the indictment was found
unless good cause was shown for a delay
parker circuit court opened its term in
jefferson county on october 20th 1859
and it was obligated by law to move on
to winchester and
frederick county no later than november
10th
brown's indictment was returned by the
ground grand jury in october 26th
it thus followed that absent good cause
for a delay
brown and the other six men who were
captured with him
in harpers ferry all had to be
tried and executed before november 10th
since brown's trial
did not begin until october 26th this
meant that these seven men all had to be
tried in the short space of 12 days
sundays of course were excluded
virginia law also provided that each of
the men was entitled to be tried
separately
if the trial of any one of them was
delayed beyond november 10th he would
have to be held in jail until the
circuit court returned to charlestown
the following april
during the intervening six months the
untried prisoners would have to be
guarded
against a possible rescue attempt from
the north
this was a prospect that local officials
considered a real possibility
as did governor wise who ordered
hundreds of militiamen to charlestown to
guard the courthouse
and the jail against possible attack
so parker urged on by the prosecutors
and by governor wise
proceeded to conduct the trials with all
possible haste
in one of his letters to governor wise
andrew hunter wrote that parker was
quote
for observing all the judicial decencies
unquote
so am i hunter told the governor but at
double quick
time
and so the trial got underway even
before brown's
own attorneys
were able to arrive in charlestown when
the boyish george hoyt arrived from
boston brown's appointed attorneys
withdrew from the case
leaving the 21 year old novice to try to
resurrect the shambles that the trial
had become
and by the time that brown's chosen
attorneys from ohio and washington dc
uh hiram griswold and samuel chilton
arrived in the scene the witnesses had
all been examined and there was nothing
left to do but present closing arguments
and so the trial
hurtled forward toward the verdict
the haste with which the trial was
conducted was not judge parker's
particular fault he was a good judge the
heir of a long and distinguished line of
virginia jurists and judge sanders
alluded to his father
judge richard parker senior he was born
in richmond in 1810 he graduated from
the university of virginia and he
practiced law in winchester and
charlestown before serving for 10 years
as military store keeper and paymaster
in harpers ferry he was a
elected to congress in 1849 but resigned
after about a year and a half to become
circuit judge he knew the law well
and he had a good judicial temperament
but he was determined to try brown and
his co-defendants before november 10th
and he did all in his power to achieve
that result
there's little doubt at least little
doubt in my own mind
that brown was guilty of the charges
brought against him
there were many witnesses who saw him in
harper's ferry during his raid
and they all testified against him
he was not an innocent man
at least not if guilt or innocence is
determined by the
laws of virginia
which after all are the laws under which
he was tried
but even guilty men are entitled to fair
trials in the american system
brown's trial raised serious legal
questions the issue of whether the
crimes he was charged with were properly
tried in a virginia state court rather
than a federal district court was raised
during the trial but never persuasively
answered whether brown could properly be
charged with treason against the
commonwealth of virginia even though he
was not a resident of virginia was
another key issue
judge parker ruled that he could be
because as a citizen of the united
states
he owed allegiance to virginia and to
all of the states of the american union
this question has been hotly debated by
historians over the generations
and there are arguments on both sides i
however
believe that judge parker got it right
and that brown was
properly tried for treason against
virginia
i discussed the reasons for that
conclusion in my book
brown's chosen attorneys griswold and
chilton argued during the trial that
during their closing arguments
that the proof offered during the trial
was not adequate to sustain
all of the charges in the indictment
but the jury disagreed
and after only 45 minutes of
deliberation
they returned their verdict
brown was guilty
after the sentence was passed chilton
filed a petition for a writ of error
with the supreme court of appeals in
richmond
but the petition was denied without a
written opinion
it was an odd conclusion
to a judicial proceeding that all
virginians recognized as perhaps the
most contentious ever conducted in
virginia
certainly it was the highest profile
trial ever conducted on virginia soil
with daily reports printed on the front
pages of newspapers all over the country
and yet the judges of the supreme court
of appeals in richmond
did not consider the case important
enough to hold a hearing
or to file an opinion explaining their
decision
these judges like the officials in
charlestown
were slave holders
i consider the question of the fairness
of brown's trial at some length in my
book i quote the historians and lawyers
who have over the years expressed their
opinions on the subject
i also quote the statements that judge
parker and andrew hunter made
on that very question when as uh old men
they were asked for their recollections
of the trial
not surprisingly both parker and hunter
thought the trial was fair in all
respects
i think their arguments were good but
not conclusive but whether brown's trial
was fair or not
is not in my opinion the right
question to ask about this really
extraordinary judicial event
there was never any real question that
brown would be convicted in charlestown
and that he would be hanged
but that's not what made his trial so
important to history
brown did not take the witness stand
during his trial he never testified in
fact he had no right to testify for the
law of england of the united states had
traditionally forbidden parties from
testifying in their own cases
it was deemed that any person who had a
personal interest in a case would
inevitably lie
even if
it was under oath and so they were not
permitted to offer sworn testimony it
was only after the civil war that this
rule was changed so the criminal
defendants were permitted to testify in
their own cases
now of course it's accepted that all
criminal defendants have the right to
testify
although they also had the right to
remain silent the choice is theirs it
was not so at the time of brown's trial
and brown made no effort to take the
witness stand
even though he did not testify however
he did find opportunities to speak
during his trial he addressed the court
he sought short delays in the
proceedings he asked some questions of
the witnesses
he reminded the judges and the jury
several times that he had been promised
a fair trial
and in the end he took advantage of the
opportunity that the law allowed him
to make a statement in his own words
before a sentence was passed
and when brown spoke he did so in strong
and earnest words at one point when
george parker denied a request for a
delay brown
raised himself up on the cot in which he
was lying and said
if we are to be forced with a mere form
a trial for execution you might spare
yourselves that trouble
i am ready for that fate
during his famous last statement
he stated that his purpose in coming
into
harford's ferry was not to kill or
injure or destroy property
only
to help the slaves
i deny everything he said but what i
have all along admitted
of a design on my part to free slaves
had he come there he said on behalf of
the rich the powerful the intelligent
the so-called great in behalf of any of
their friends
it would have been all right every man
in this court would have deemed it an
act worthy of reward rather than
punishment
i see a book kissed he said
which i suppose to be the bible or at
least the new testament
which teaches me that all things
whatsoever
i would that men should do to me
i should do so even so to them
it teaches me further to remember them
that are in bonds as bound with them
i endeavor to act up to that instruction
i am yet too young to understand that
god is any respecter of persons i
believe that to have interfered as i
have done
as i have always freely admitted i have
done in behalf of his despised poor
is no wrong but right
now if it is deemed necessary that i
should forfeit my life for the
furtherance of the ends of justice
and mingle my blood further with the
blood of my children
and with the blood of millions
in this slave country whose rights are
disregarded by wicked
cruel and unjust enactments
i say
let it be done
the way brown spoke during his trial the
way he conducted himself before
during and after the proceedings won the
grudging admiration of even the most
fervent slave holders
the words he spoke inspired listeners
both north and south with their
sincerity and raw courage
emerson later ranked brown's last
statement with lincoln's gettysburg
address as one of the two best specimens
of eloquence we have had in this country
governor wise expressed himself
so satisfied with brown that he
proclaimed him a man of clear head of
courage fortitude and simple
ingenuousness
and he said that brown inspired him with
his integrity
as a man of truth
notwithstanding all of this the governor
refused to grant brown clemency
and he took an active role in making the
preparations for his hanging
just south of charlestown
why do i consider john brown's trial the
most important trial in american history
it's quite simply because of its
consequences
because of what happened after it was
concluded because of the causal effect
it had on the great civil war that
followed it so quickly
and because of the blow it struck
against the institution of chattel
slavery
let's assume for purposes of discussion
that brown was at least in part
responsible for the civil war that began
just a little over one year
after the trial in charlestown ended
let's assume also that his raid on
harpers ferry aroused passions all over
the country convincing southerners that
political maneuvering was no longer
adequate to protect slavery from its
northern enemies that secession from the
union
and military defense of the confederate
states of america was necessary to
achieve that goal
these are all reasonable assumptions
they have been made by historians
for generations
but let's also assume
that the raid on harper's ferry was the
last
we ever heard of john brown
let's assume that he was shot and killed
during the fighting in harpers ferry
as he nearly
was or lynched by the mob that was
hungering for vengeance after he was
captured
as he nearly was
or that governor wise had convened a
court martial and condemned him to death
within hours of his capture wise wanted
to do that very thing but he arrived in
harpers ferry too late
let's assume in other words that there
was no trial in charlestown
no magistrates court no grand jury no
indictment no jury no verdict no appeal
to the supreme court of appeals in
richmond
if that had been the case brown would
never have had an opportunity
to address the court he could not have
made the statements quoted over and over
in newspaper uh reports
reprinted in newspapers all over the
united states and later celebrated by
emerson and others
his voice would never have been heard
in public
he would be known for his violence
in harpers ferry
but not for his eloquence and humanity
in this courthouse in charlestown
he would have been dismissed as a
fanatic an extremist
who was willing to take the law into his
own hands a madman
who was willing to shed innocent life to
achieve a political goal but was caught
in the act and stopped
what would brown's legacy have been in
such a case
in my opinion
it would have been practically nothing
at least far less than it was in fact
it was because he survived to stand
trial in charlestown that we remembered
him
tonight
it was because he spoke so eloquently in
judge parker's courtroom
enunciating the moral vision that
brought him into harpers ferry in the
first place
it was because he delivered his last
statement before judge parker and
because he expressed his willingness to
die for his convictions
that we remember him today as a
visionary
an idolist an idealist
and ultimately a martyr to the cause
of human freedom
and these memories are still potent
because of john brown's trial
because of the four days when attorneys
and witnesses and jurors
decided brown's fate
in this courthouse
during those four days the nation
watched john brown listen to and speak
pondered his message
and set the nation on the court course
to civil war
to the emancipation of the slaves
and to the new birth of freedom that
lincoln spoke of at gettysburg
and it all began here in the jefferson
county courthouse
where we are gathered this evening
thank you
thank you
i should have said at the beginning that
i will be happy
to sign books but i want to amend that
statement to say i would be delighted to
sign books
particularly if you buy them before i
sign them but the books are on the table
here and
before we get to the book signing let's
have some questions and answers and
don't make them too hard because i'm not
good at answering hard questions
you sir in the blue shirt yes
um in regards to john brown's supposed
treason against the state of virginia on
the ground
that because he was a citizen of the
united states he was therefore subject
to the laws of virginia correct so
it's ironic i find that the state of
virginia which put those uh
prosecuted for that did not uphold
itself to those same loyalty to the
united states a little a year later when
it seceded from the union enjoyed the
join the confederacy and i was curious
did that same judge support the
confederacy and therefore break his own
ruling that he prosecuted john brown on
okay that's uh there are whole libraries
on that subject
and some of them are very good judge
parker was a state judge
he was
a judge under the authority of the laws
and constitution of the commonwealth of
virginia and when the commonwealth of
virginia seceded from the union judge
parker went with it
i think his you you can judge from the
fact that he owned 10 slaves that he
probably wasn't very happy with what
john brown was trying to do here
whether he was guilty of any hypocrisy
or not i don't know i don't accuse the
people who left the union at the time of
the civil war with hypocrisy but he
probably uh did sympathize with the
confederacy
but uh
he may have had some good reason for
doing so because
he was a virginian and he owed his
office to the commonwealth of virginia
another question
yes sir
larry lawrence from the john brown
society i thank you sir for your efforts
i have come to the conclusion
after thinking about john brown for over
20 years
and considering that the united states
government has never done a postage
stamp the post office has never done a
postage stamp to honor john brown
that there is a continuity with the
capitalist imperialist u.s government
today
and the slave-owning u.s government of
the past
with the decision of president james
buchanan
to send colonel robert e lee
leading the u.s marines to capture brown
after he went into the u.s arsenal
that the united states government
to this day
despises john brown
when fighters for justice for the poor
all over the world people i've known
from
south america south africa europe and
asia love john brown
that there is a strange continuity that
continues
with the u.s well thank you sir i
appreciate those remarks
they're not really jermaine to the trial
so so i think that we will consider your
remarks and
and yes sir
as i listen to you talk about the trial
i'm thinking of the
trial of the
german resistance uh to the uh nazi
regime uh the uh the white rose
defendants and also the
so-called red orchestra
again they were charged with treason in
this case to the nazi regime tried
before a nazi corps and presided over by
nazi party judges even so-called
defended by members of the nazi party
such as it was
how was the john brown trial for treason
before the judge and jury and
slaveholders any different in your
estimation
well that's an argument you've made a
good argument there and
certainly there's
a good body of opinion that would agree
with you on the other hand there are
people who
do not look so favorably on john brown
john brown is a controversial figure in
american history i think he
will probably always be a controversial
figure in american history and we have
to
recognize that out of that controversy
arrives
different opinions i've expressed my
opinion here and probably agrees with
you yours but
there are others who don't don't share
that opinion
yes sir getting back to here
can you tell us what happened to the
other defendants what happened well they
were all hanged they were all hanged um
there was at one time there was a uh
an effort made to try one of the
defendants in federal court and the
purpose for that
was so that they could
subpoena
people outside of virginia to testify in
the trial the
process of a federal court extends
beyond
the borders of the state whereas the
state court can only subpoena witnesses
within the state
and governor wise was
strongly of the opinion that there were
men who were
uh complicit with brown and the raiden
harpers ferry who were um
seeking to avoid justice in new york and
in boston
but that effort wasn't made and
that man was tried here and also hanged
there was another a man named john cook
who was um
the brother-in-law of the governor of
indiana
and the governor came here
and uh
pled for his life and urged him to
confess
to make a confession ask for the mercy
of the court and ask governor wise for
clemency he did that
was uh quickly tried convicted sentenced
to hang and hanged and governor wise did
not extend clemency were the charges
basically same and were they all hanged
here in charge yes they were they were
all based on the harpist ferry raid they
were all on nearly identical charges
there were there were with with two
exceptions and this is a really
interesting exception if
two of the defendants
were what they used to call
colored men
one was what they called and i i use
this word
hoping i don't give offense to anyone a
mulatto but he was of mixed race
but of course he was classified as a
black person the same as any others they
were free men
and
they were charged with treason against
the commonwealth of virginia as brown
and the other defendants were
their attorneys were smart men however
their attorneys were from the north
and they said judge chief justice roger
chaney has recently
made a decision in the supreme court of
the united states
that anyone of african descent cannot be
a citizen
of the united states
if you can't be a citizen of the united
states how can you be a citizen of the
commonwealth of virginia and if you're
not a citizen how can you be charged
with treason against the commonwealth of
virginia
well they considered those arguments and
they said yep you got us there so they
dropped the treason charges and hanged
them for murder and and inciting a
rebellion
yes sir
well treason is defined in the united
states constitution in a very specific
way it is the only crime
that is defined in the united states
constitution and i'm not going to try to
read you the definition from memory hill
because i'll leave a word out or
do something wrong certainly the
virginia definition of treason was
statutory but it was modeled on the uh
american
on the definition in the united states
constitution it essentially was
making war against the government or
giving aid and comfort to its enemies
though that's kind of the essence of the
crime
so the question was argued also during
the trial even though it was a short
trial there were a lot of issues that
had to be argued did john brown make war
on the commonwealth of virginia his
attorneys made a good argument that he
didn't do that
that he in effect he had just formed a
club it was kind of like a
an optimist club or an elks club or
something like that had a constitution
but of course they didn't buy that
argument and yet
yes yes sir yes a general judge with
jurisdiction over this area had decided
to assert jurisdiction
were laws in place where the federal
government could have asserted supremacy
and stopped the state trial no
jurisdiction no
no there is no provision in the
constitutional system for the federal
government to interfere with the
exercise of proper jurisdiction by state
court and judge parker opined on that
very subject and he said once john brown
is in the custody of state officials
he will remain there until they have
dealt with them according to state laws
uh if they if he should be released then
federal officials might have arrested
them and then tried him for a federal
offense but
since he was dead at the time of his
release it wouldn't wouldn't have
accomplished very much
back in the back row yes sir i'm curious
about what the atmosphere was like in
the courtroom and the environment around
town was uh security very tight was
there a lot of army before militia
troops around during the trial were
weapons allowed in the courtroom
what was was okay that's that's a great
question
the streets were crowded with militiamen
judge
governor wise had ordered militia here
from richmond from various other parts
of
virginia they set up
cannons in front of the courthouse and
in front of the jail
there were cannons aimed at the jail and
at the courthouse in case anyone should
try to
help brown escape
it was like an armed camp outside
outside the building outside the
courthouse not inside the courthouse
however because judge parker objected
to any military display inside the
courthouse
and at one time there was a soldier that
came in the uh and in the courtroom uh
during the course of the trial and judge
sark uh judge parker rather irately
ordered him to leave
now that that's another there are lots
of interesting little twists and turns
to this story
after the trial was over after the civil
war began this courthouse was used by
both union
and
southern troop confederate troops
at various times as one army would come
in and push the other out they would set
up here in the court in the courthouse
and they would use it as a barracks
so that the area around judge parker's
bench
i had soldiers sleeping all over it
judge parker didn't like
the
weapons or soldiers in his courtroom but
there wasn't very much he could do about
it when the armies came through
yes sir what extent did wise um
struggle with the decision to execute
brown i know he was people sent him
letters warning him not to do that that
it would have a the martyr effect and
i'm just curious about his uh
judge wise
was as generally being characterized as
a
mercurial changeable man
who uh changed his mind a lot
i was an emotional man
a very
intelligent man he was an attorney
a well-experienced attorney
and he cared a lot about the decisions
that were made here
but nobody was ever quite sure
what he would ultimately decide here now
this is another little interesting twist
on this story i
think when the charges were first filed
against john brown here before the
indictment was returned
the charges did not include treason
it was only when the indictment was
filed that
our friend andrew hunter inserted
account for treason against the
commonwealth
there was a man who lived in charleston
by the name of boyd stutter who was a
great brown scholar and i discovered
this from reading his papers in the west
virginia archives now
he was of the opinion and he said but he
couldn't find any documentary evidence
on it that hunter had inserted
the
count charging brown with treason
so that wise would not be able to
reprieve him because under the law at
that time wise as the governor had the
power to reprieve or to grant clemency
for murder
for inciting slaves to rebellion for
aiding a betting murder which were the
other trials the other charges in the
case
he did not have the power to grant
clemency for treason without the consent
of the uh
the general assembly which is the state
legislature and uh scotland was at the
opinion that knowing that wise was a
it was a vacillator
and that you didn't know exactly what
his final decision would be he put in
the trees in charge to tie his hands
but that that may or may not hold water
uh
look uh read about it in the book
because wise could have applied to the
legislature for permission to do this
and he did not he did not and i think
that he felt he was running for
president at the time he thought that he
was a moderate southerner who might be
elected as president of the united
states he was a little mistaken in that
regard a fellow from illinois made it
instead
but
he was trying to appeal to moderates on
both sides both in the north and the
south
and so he did vacillate
yes ma'am
what brown was looking for in attorney
well he he left a lot of letters there
are a lot of john brown's letters
and he wanted a uh someone who would
sympathize with him
someone who was a good attorney
but he also he made it quite clear in
one of his letters
do not send an ultra abolitionist
he didn't want an ultra abolitionist
because he knew that that would arouse
antipathy here in charlestown and it
would probably do him more harm than
good to have an attorney like that
yes sir
those were the private attorneys they
were griswold and chilton chilton took
most responsibility for it
there was another attorney in richmond
by the name of green i believe his name
was william greene who was a brother of
thomas claiborne green the mayor who had
represented brown
by court appointment in the early stages
of this trial here but chilton and
griswold presented the arguments in
richmond with the assistance of william
green
and their petition exists it's a very
rare document
i had a chance to read it in richmond
and it was
very very well presented and at the time
the
statutes of virginia provided that the
judges of the supreme court of appeals
were to state the reasons for their
decisions in writing
now they never made
a they never issued an opinion in the
brown case
you know it was a it was a terribly
contentious case very controversial it
was on the minds of people throughout
the united states and yet they denied
the petition without a formal opinion
they did leave a one sentence opinion in
in effect saying that
they denied the petition because the
decision of the circuit court had
obviously been right something to that
effect it was really like a one sentence
conclusion
yes sir
can you tell me if the charges and
conviction for treason against the state
of virginia or for that matter or any
other state was unique
to those involved with harper's ferry or
have there been subsequent
cases and convictions of individuals
treason against the state of virginia or
any other state well i believe there was
a trial here in 1922
when it involved treason against
virginia
so that was another one
west virginia yeah
i don't know of any others against
virginia there were
there were prosecutions for treason
against
states earlier before john brown's trial
but they were very rare there was one in
rhode island
uh which had arisen out of in effect uh
a rebellion there to overthrow the state
government
and another in new york that had
had something to do with the war of 1812
with people who were supplying
british ships in the harbor with
with
necessary material for the war and they
were charged with treason against new
york and as i recall the decision in
that case was
helping uh helping the british defeat
the united states is not treason against
new york it might be treason against the
united states but not against new york
so there were other cases but they were
very rare and to my
to the best of my knowledge that was
and i think it's well documented the
first
uh execution
for treason against the state
yes sir
uh do you think that john brown's
conception or understanding of this
trial changed as it went on yes i do i
really think that i think that there was
a change in brown i think in the
beginning that he thought
that he might actually
um
be held not
be found not guilty
because of the fact that he didn't
really intend to do any harm here i
think it was naive
but i think that he really did believe
that and he did really want some
attorneys who might help him prove that
case
very quickly however he changed his mind
and he decided that it was far better
for him to be executed
for his noble cause
than for him to be found not guilty or
or to escape from jail if he could have
done that
yes ma'am
one of the things that he did
and it doesn't seem like any of the
charges cover that was
well i'm quite sure it was a crime it
was not charged per se
it was
part of the
inciting slaves to rebellion part of the
um
perhaps aiding and abetting murder
because um
there were
four civilians who were killed in
harpers ferry were shot dead during the
fighting that ensued it is uh it is
interesting that there was no
charge of uh
kidnapping there was nothing of that
kind that was
a file against brown
and by the way so the some of the
hostages that he took
and he and he kept them in the
fire engine house in harpers ferry which
you can visit now today
they were in there for
maybe 24 hours some some period of time
had very nice things to say about him
he was uh
treated them with respect
uh
did not abuse them
and
as a matter of fact we were discussing
this this afternoon a couple of them
said well i my my wife is worrying about
me at home
and i haven't had any breakfast
and he said well go home and
and have breakfast get your wife and
give you some breakfast but come back
here and take your place as a hostage
and they did so that's exactly what they
did they went home had breakfast they
came back and took their places hostages
um would you repeat that please i missed
the beginning
could that have been the reason
that that charge specifically wasn't
included that might have been that might
have been i think however that a lot of
the mistakes that were made during the
trial can be attributed to the rush to
judgment if you have a trial like this
that really involve
fundamental legal questions and you have
19 witnesses that you're going to call
to testify
and you have to swear have a a jury in a
sworn
summon from from the outlying areas of
the county and you have a
an indictment that takes 20 minutes to
to be read in open court you're going to
make a lot of mistakes trying to do all
that in such a short time and that's
what they did but i don't think they
were terribly worried about the mistakes
because they
they regarded it as an inevitability
that brown would be uh convicted and
hanged and they were right
yes sir
two questions uh when brown surrendered
he was in the custody of the united
states army how did they lose
and control their prisoner to the state
authorities and secondly did his ground
provisional constitution
play any part in his conviction
well i think i i didn't get your first
part where brown was in the cusp of the
us
he's surrendering to the united states
oh well when lee and his marines
yeah they captured him they turned him
over to the state authorities
quite quickly and this was another
perhaps another mistake if they had been
turned over instead to the uh
us marshall or the eastern district of
virginia he could have then he would
have been in federal custody and would
have been tried in federal court and it
would have would have taken a lot longer
because the federal court
had to
convene it was meeting in southern
virginia at the time and
it wouldn't have rushed to judgment
there wouldn't have been such a rush
to judgment and the state would have
been helpless at that point they could
not demand it but
there was a conference a hurried
conference
in washington between james buchanan and
the
united states attorney
about what will we do about this
about john brown
and governor wise was quite adamant
the state of the commonwealth of
virginia will take custody of john brown
and deal with him according to the laws
of the commonwealth of virginia that's
all there is to it
and brown said well he didn't care
particularly one way or the other so he
let them do
it it was introduced in evidence in the
trial and portions of it were read to
the jury
yes
yes sir
i think everybody's dreaming that he
should have been tried in the federal
court but if he'd been tried in federal
court with the evidence would he still
have been convicted and harmed
yes i think he would have been
oh that that satisfies you
well i think he would have been he was
he broke the law
i mean he broke the law in a violent way
you break the law in a violent way they
don't say
go home and don't do it again they they
in those days they
they strung you up and hanged you i
think that would have been that would
have happened but it would have been a
much different trial in many respects
one one important different would would
be that the aggrieved party in that case
would have been the united states of
america
seeking to
vindicate its laws to enforce its rule
to enforce its order as it was it was
the commonwealth of virginia
vindicating its laws it was a different
focus entirely
and brown would not have been and would
not have perhaps aroused as much
terrible opposition if it hadn't been
that
it was made to seem that he had offended
virginia in fact he offended the entire
united states when he broke the law
in my opinion
yes sir
um andrew uh hunter cited precedent at
one point regarding jurisdiction and in
your book do you look into that as the
murder of the u.s superintendent of the
army
oh yes
you're referring to the earlier uh
trial that had
arisen out of the uh harpers ferry
yeah uh well hunter had a good point
there there had been a murder that took
place in harpers ferry around 1930 the
superintendent was
murdered in cold blood by a disgruntled
employee who had been laid off and he
was very angry he went into the
superintendent's office and shot him to
death he was brought to charlestown and
tried here in charlestown and hanged
and hunter cited that as a president he
said we've always done it this way
crimes arising out of harpers fair the
armory and arsenal harpers ferry have
been tried in charlestown
and so that it's good and uh
um
the the the slight problem with that
argument is if you do things wrong one
time doesn't necessarily mean you can do
it wrong twice
yes
i have a question more about your
writing process in creating a book
since you mentioned that there were no
transcripts of the trial and and i
realized no official trends no official
transcripts and you did uh research
which also involved
all looking at these newspaper articles
and this
sensationalism that was attending the
trial i wonder if you had any trouble or
a great deal of trouble
struggling with what was
what was being honestly reported versus
uh flooredly reported or editorialized
and if you can comment on that well
there is some difficulty in that in in
particular
there were several of the
new york newspapers that were
represented here during the trial
and one of them ran afoul of the local
authorities for of
writing unfavorable reports about
charlestown
can't imagine what there would have been
unfavorable that happened here at the
time but
he thought there was and he wrote some
stories and they took offense at that
and they
told him to get out of town he had 24
hours to leave town he did and he went
uh i think he was the writer for the uh
for the tribune
orth greely's newspaper and i believe
that he went up to
either baltimore and philadelphia and
filed some more stories that were even
more unfavorable about charlestown in
which and some people have accused him
of making up some of the stories now
there were some some were
there were some
good ones in in those stories one was
that the the floor of the courtroom
at the time was covered with
pecan and pecan pecan and peanut shells
that the people were just rabidly you
know chewing on pecans and peanuts and
throwing their shells on the floor and
when you would walk across the floor it
would
sound like you were walking on broken
glass
and
i don't know whether this reporter for
the new york newspaper made that story
up or whether it was really true it
wasn't in the other newspapers
yes sir go ahead
lipstick
shall we go to the signing team
thank you mr mcginnie i think we need to
give him a break he'll be delighted to
sign your book if you care to purchase
one the historical society is selling
the books this evening and of course mr
mcginty will be at harpers ferry at the
conference tomorrow maybe you'll have
a chance to catch him there
for the humanities council we thank you
all for being here and certainly we
thank brian mcginney for an excellent
speech this evening thank you sir
[Applause]
brian mcginty is the author of lincoln
and the court october 16th marked the
150th anniversary of john brown's raid
for more information visit
johnbrownraid.org